uh all right let's talk about
Yellowstone TV's number one hit series
is officially coming to an end yeah we
were there were rumors we were talking
about yeah Yellowstone is the most
popular show in is that why they had so
many spin-offs because they knew it was
coming to an end because it's so good no
I think it's just so good it's good it
is
network is announced the final seasons
will debut in November we don't know if
the star Kevin Costner is going to
appear there's been a report that he
would not return for season five's
remaining episodes after tension with
Yellowstone co-creator Taylor Sheridan
Paramount only says quote Kevin Costner
is a big part of Yellowstone and we hope
that's the case for a long time to come
yes a new Untitled Yellowstone sequel
was already in the works for December on
Paramount Network and we'll stream later
on Paramount plus the cast will be
announced shortly of course Paramount
Network like CBS is owned by Paramount
Global
we want to see Kevin we do want to see
Kevin Costner I hope whatever this is
out I hope he sticks around as well I
mean they might have you know
Yellowstone is fantastic it's so good
going off after season five might
actually in the long run be a good thing
I know no one wants it but you know the
show will remain good through the end I
hope the other I hope I hope Costner
stays but I also hope the cast of the
original Yellowstone sticks around
because they are amazing they are
amazing and uh yeah I could do that
airport I'm here for it
we have a very special edition of what
to watch NFL fans are probably drooling
right now uh see those cool graphics yes
I think is that you're not made me those
Graphics made me think that you were
like a sports expert I saw vladimirucci
no but you know who in the NFL sports
expert I'm gonna bring in JB because we
are highlighting some Marquee matchups
coming up to CBS this New Year's Eve
it's a battle featuring two of the top
quarterbacks in the league Joe burrow
and the Cincinnati Cincinnati Bengals
will travel to Kansas City to take on
Patrick Mahomes in the Super Bowl
champion Chiefs on Sunday December 31st
so this expert that I'm talking about
Tony of course to break down this
matchup is James Brown host of the NFL
today on CBS JB good morning my brother
hey vlant don't Tony and Gail know that
you are the sports expert we do this
every week during the football season
there you go I got a lot of people fool
JB but let me ask you about uh the most
anticipated Game of the Year Chiefs
Bengals they met in the last two AFC
Championship Games what makes this
rivalry so special
look quarterback rivalries Drive the
league and they make no mistake about it
it is a quarterback driven League it's
very offensively friendly these two guys
get it done they're in the same
conference in the AFC so it lends itself
to a rivalry which every football fan
loves think Tom Brady Peyton Manning if
you will in the recent past these two
guys have said it Joe burrow has a 3-1
record against the best quarterback in
the game right now today that being
Patrick Mahomes so all the storylines
are just great and we at CBS Sports
could not be happier than to have the
matchup that has delivered massive
ratings each time these guys have gone
at it I love that JB we also have the
Super Bowl I was about to say yeah have
you heard in Las Vegas what teams May
contend for that championship game
while in the championship game on the
AFC side of the house clearly you have
to look at these two squads there the
Buffalo Bills are very much in the mix
and I would dare say Lamar Jackson is
going to have a little bit to say about
things coming into the season with
Baltimore now that he's All Inked Up
there's some great quarterbacks out
there as well in the AM we're looking
forward to it JB hope we can join you
there uh thank you very much all right
finally a superstar has returned to the
concert today of course we're all
talking about Beyonce and the Beehive
yeah
so Beyonce opened a Renaissance tour in
Stockholm Sweden last night the vibe a
futuristic disco Extravaganza Beyonce
even performed some robot moves it's her
first solo tour in nearly seven years
get this the setlist
37 songs features favorites like
Dangerously in Love and she's saying
every single track from the Renaissance
album Wow Let's call the Renaissance
tour that's right every single song she
will return to North America in July
folks I know people that are like
getting multiple they're going to like
Stockholm all over the world and hoping
to see the concert in LA which will be
around her birthday yes September 4th
yeah September 4th and people think that
it could be a Humdinger I'm already
trying to come back but Tyler Perry was
in the audience last night standing next
to Jay-Z in blue I mean I know some
people who were there that said it was
insane yeah insane you had some you
posted
let's talk about our boy our friend our
colleague Nate Burleson who went to
Chicago to talk with former president
Barack Obama and he was sharing some
exciting news from the My Brother's
Keeper Alliance which is an Obama
Foundation program that tries to put
young men of color on a path of success
on Wednesday the former president joined
leaders of the alliance to announce a
new initiative it aims to expand
practices like reducing gun violence and
keeping kids in school that have proven
to be successful in four model
communities the former president talked
to Nate about gun violence in our
country yeah Isn't that cool oh man look
at Nate wearing a tan suit I wonder if
that's I wonder if there's that's a good
question uh yeah it tells me it was on
for because I said what are you going to
wear he goes oh I got something planned
on purpose
uh so this is an organization just
trying to make a change and he was
talking to the former president about
what keeps him up at night you saw that
video uh so Nate's interview will be on
Tuesday right here on CBS mornings I I
was talking I heard it went well yeah I
was talking to Mary who's uh Nate's AP
and he said it was an amazing experience
and that the former president is what
you would expect him to be never met him
in person but warm and exciting cool all
those things you know smart yeah yes